welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Professor John Romer the Elizabeth s
and a very stout professor of political
science and economics professor roamers
research concerns political economy and
distributive justice his books include
racism xenophobia and distribution
democracy education and equality
political competition equality of
opportunity and theories of distributive
justice professor Romer is here today to
talk about the future of capitalism
welcome professor Romer Thank You Harlan
in your most recent work you explore the
future of capitalism give us your
perspective well because we're in this
massive crisis a lot of people are
talking about what should be done to
prevent these crises from happening in
the future as well as obviously solving
the present crisis but I think there's
been a wrongheaded approach to the
question of how to prevent these crises
in the future in the following sense
that all the discussants in this debate
or almost all of them take people as
they are including people on Wall Street
and truck and are trying to design
techniques to make sure that a system
which is run by people who a financial
sector that's run in large part by
people who are out to maximize their
wealth and our greedy that will work
even under such a system and I think the
history of capitalism shows that there's
really no way of designing a foolproof
set of rules that will work if there are
intelligent and avaricious people who
want to circumvent them ok so how do the
preferences of individuals fit into your
theory so there's been a
there's been a very active area of
research in economics over the last 30
years which attempts to design rules
which will lead people regardless of
what their values or preferences are to
do things which are in socially optimal
good for the welfare of people
the simplest example with which most
people are familiar is the Adam Smith
quote that if even though the baker and
the candlestick maker and so on are out
for their own good and not to maximize
their own profits in a market system
with competition if they do so that will
lead to the social good well there's
been a lot of criticism of that naive
less a fair philosophy in in the last
hundred years at least and but the in
the last thirty years as I said there's
been an effort in economics to see if
they can if we can design more
sophisticated systems of rules that will
work even when people are greedy and
avaricious and are only looking out for
themselves work in the sense of
delivering outcomes that are good for
society and in fact the Nobel Prize was
awarded to three economists two years
ago who were instrumental in developing
this this area my view however is that
it's really not going to be possible to
design such rules given people who are
avaricious and out only for themselves
that the only hope of designing rules
which will bring about a good outcome in
society and in a market economy is if
people's preferences change and become
more concerned with other people more
solid heuristic you argue that crises
can bring about greater social insurance
what do you mean by that
so how would preferences change I I'm
not a utopian in the sense that I don't
believe that
jawboning by
even as charismatic a politician as
Barack Obama or other leaders or more
ethics courses and business schools is
going to be enough to get people to
think more solid heuristically I think
however that there are laws of motion of
the development of solidarity and my own
view is that crises can start off a
sequence of events that may end up in
people's becoming more solid heuristic
and changing their values and their
preferences do you think that it's
possible for capitalism to achieve
stability and relative equality of
condition
so let me let me before I get to that
let me explain this sequence of events
so one thing that crises do is they tend
to reduce all people to the same
situation they wipe out wealth they in
particular they make the risks that
different people face much more similar
than they were before the crisis so
middle class people let's say and
working-class people now are facing
risks which are much more similar with
respect to unemployment and the
possibility of financing their
retirement than was the case before the
crisis and when people face risks that
when people have risk exposures which
are very similar in terms of the chances
of good and bad things happening to them
it's much easier to design universal
insurance everybody will want the
insurance and so in particular I think
that one good consequence of this
current crisis every cloud has a silver
lining is that national health insurance
will be much easier to pass now because
there'll be much more universal support
for it I think once these insurance
insurance is extended in this manner
then I think people's preferences change
because they like they begin to like
the society where a certain kind of
poverty is eliminated there won't be
people without insurance there won't be
crowded emergency rooms full of
uninsured poor people who can't get care
any other way and even costs will
probably go down because or they won't
accelerate so fast because with
universal insurance the the government
will have a an incentive to keep prices
down and for instance drug prices so it
seems to me that what will happen is
after the passage of health insurance
people will come to like that new kind
of society just the way people came to
like the system with Social Security
after 1935 despite the fact that the
right wing had opposed Social Security
very strenuously as they are now or have
been opposing national health insurance
in the past 20 years so my view is that
insurance which is initially adopted
because from a self-interested viewpoint
people are facing the same risks and so
they want the everybody wants the
insurance then people begin to like the
new society and their preferences become
somewhat more desiring of equality and
then they go farther they pass new kinds
of social insurance because their
preferences have changed and they want
to get rid of other kinds of poverty and
other kinds of inequality so I think a
crisis can set in motion sequence of
insurance followed by preference changes
followed by more insurance which leads
to more quality and I think there are
two major historical examples of this in
recent history one is the Great
Depression which made people so similar
in their risk profiles that there was
support for Social Security and the
other was the Second World War which
wiped out a lot of wealth in Europe and
in Japan and homogenized people's risk
exposures in that sense and the
consequence of the second world war was
a massive growth in the welfare state
after the Second World War that is to
say many more insurance programs were
voted in by citizens as a consequence I
think
of the crisis of the war okay you cite
the Scandinavian experience as
particularly successful do you think the
US can learn something from them so I
think Scandinavia is often cited as a
special case because they these are
small countries the Nordic countries and
they're at least in the time when they
enacted their the legislation which
brought about their welfare states there
were very homogeneous countries with
respect to ethnic city and language and
religion and so many people say that
there was a natural solidarity among
Scandinavians because of theirs their
racial and similarities and religious
homogeneity and so on and so they had a
natural feeling of solidarity for each
other and that's when engendered the
large welfare states I actually
challenge that view I think that this
that the homogeneity of Scandinavia was
important because it also meant that the
people were very similar with respect to
the risks they faced with respect to
illness and with respect to unemployment
and wit and longevity so the and I think
it was that homogeneity of the risk
exposures which made it easy for the
welfare state to get started in these
countries and then the process that I
mentioned I think took over and the
Scandinavian countries have gone much
farther than simple self-interested
insurance would require now as far as
the United States is concerned you said
what's the lesson for the u.s. well the
parallel I'm drawing is that we're now
in a crisis which is going to homogenize
people with respect to their risk
exposures at least the working class in
the middle class to some extent and I
think that will form a powerful
electoral block or support for social
insurance which will then change
people's preferences the difference of
course between the United States and
Scandinavia is that we have a very large
minority population we're a very
heterogeneous country ethnically and I
think the racism that has been the
result of slavery
is the main reason that there hasn't
been a larger welfare state in the
United States and until now so it's been
slow going here because of the history
of slavery and the lack of solidarity
that that brought about between between
white and black citizens okay so what do
you think is the future of capitalism
here in this country it's very hard to
say I mean I don't I don't have I don't
have any crystal ball and I think there
are a lot of people who are much more
knowledgeable about the financial sector
than I am a lot of economists like Joe
Stiglitz and Paul Krugman and so on
and I look to them for instruction about
the details of what's going to happen
but my hope is as I've said that the
crisis will bring about more social
insurance for the reasons I've outlined
and the consequence of that will be that
Americans become more desirous of
equality than they currently are I mean
there are let's face it there are about
1/2 of the population of the United
States there's not particularly like
more equality I mean this is probably a
fair characterization of the people who
voted for McCain and the presidential
election which was about half the
population so I think preferences have
to change and my hope is that the crisis
will have have that good effect what the
steady state will be I don't know I mean
how egalitarian will the United States
become will it ever look like Sweden
maybe in five hundred years Wow okay
very good thank you very much for
joining us today thank you for more
information about Professor Romer and
his work please visit our website at
Yale edu backslash Macmillan Report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you